have you ever wondered of doing routine
data tasks like data info export backup
using the power of spark just passing
some arguments stay tuned date of the
templates comes to the risky this is
Balaji I am a cloud migration consultant
with Google cloud in the era of
serverless processing running spark jobs
on dedicated clusters not only at
process overhead but also take Precious
time from the developer using fully
managed on-demand servers with spark
jobs helps developers focus on their
core application logic and spend little
of more time towards the framework
Google's data proc server list on Google
Cloud platform enables customers to run
the spark workloads without having to
create or maintain the Clusters data
track serverless will take care of all
the necessary infrastructure in the
background once the spark workload
parameters have been specified and the
tasks has been submitted to the service
data prop templates are an effort to
solve simple but large in-club data
types including data import export
backup restore and bulk kPa operations
the technology under the hood which may
is possible is the serverless spark
functionality based on Google we have a
collection of pre-implemented data
templates as a reference and to provide
easy customization for developers
wanting to extend their workload
functionality without having to create
different scratch we can run typical use
cases on dataproc serverless using Java
and python thanks to data from templates
with the help of these templates we can
simply customize and run spark workloads
which are common these data templates
are needed in spark using Java Iceberg
and in Jupiter notebooks these data
templates are customizable based on the
requirements from the user this offers
the user with the power of spark and
customizing for advanced use cases is
super cool these templates are ready to
use spark workloads and they can be
configured by passing the required
arguments and triggered as a spark batch
workloads with these further use cases
can be extended and the development can
can be completed in notes High here is
the flow of data in the data protection
Linux has again Summits the data prop
templates with the required
configuration and arguments the cacd
gets triggered and it does the complete
Maven build with the required jobs once
the build is complete the required jobs
are more to the staging GCS folder your
back jar gets triggered in the data
product serverless and it can be even
monitored with the data proc UI once the
bad job is started the data product
serverless looks into the job
configuration when it starts the spark
session based on the input sources and
the output sync the data is read and
written for example when the data source
is high or pops up the data is written
right from the time first and the
required processing of data is done as
for the written logic and the process
data is written into the output sync
specified in the template may it be a
bigquery or GCS once though all the
workers gets their tasks completed a
notifications sent to shut down the
spark session and the whole back job
gets completed the status of the above
steps can be viewed either in the
console as a step-by-step process or in
the data foreign
now running these templates are super
cool it's a three-step process first
clone the repository either in your
local or in the cloud shell get into the
repository and drive us to the Java or
the python folder second after the
authentication credences with gcloud on
where it is executed it can be on your
terminal or in your Cloud shell or it
can be on your ID console as well third
step is to execute the template set the
environmental variables required then
execute the template to the required
arguments the status can be monitored
with the data proc UI here is the GitHub
link for the dataproc templates the
readme shows the complete details there
are separate sections for various
templates in Java Python and in
notebooks each section has a separate
readme files and the various steps to
execute those templates this section we
will cover Hands-On on the data talk
templates here is the git page showing
the details of the data of template in
the real mean it provides the required
details it has already mentioned that
repository can be cloned in local or in
the cloud shell from the attack there
are separate sections for the templates
using spark in Java and in five spot and
also using notebooks further it mentions
the basic steps to get started along
with showing the flow of data in the
template as well let's get into each
section here is the template written in
spark Java it has a form file which
brings in the required dependencies
during the execution of the templates
there are blog spots published in a
medium which shows complete details on
these templates
it requires basically Java version 8 and
Maven in order to proceed these
templates submit the job in the data
product serverless using back spark
Summit for execution of a template the
environmental variables needs to be set
up like the project the region the GC
staging location and the subnet now
let's take a look into the GCS to GCS
template here is the input folder which
contains the U.S state CSV file here is
the output folder with no contents let's
start with cloning the repository on the
cloud ship then travels into the Java
folder we can see the current Branch
with the git status
even the environmental variables are set
up next coming together
start script for running the GCS to GCS
template here the input file location
the output location and the project
details needs to be passed as an
argument once the job gets submitted the
entire process of build and jar creation
and learning to staging location and
submit into a batch data product
serverless is automated after build we
can see the data product server is
triggered to the gcloud batch commands
once the job gets completed it clearly
provides the details of the completed
job it can be monitored in the data proc
UI as well it shows the logs as well as
the number of workers executed if
additional logs of workers are required
then other than the batch of it can be
monitored in the view lock section this
not only covers the logger information
and errors but also gives detailed
worker level displays and notifications
as well let's refresh the output of the
GCS folder and see the output you can
see the file get copied into the output
folder
now let's get into the python templates
it's similar to the Java templates all
the network dependencies and setup are
mentioned in the requirements.txt all
needs to be done is create a virtual
environment activate it install the
requirements once this is complete we
need to set the environmental variables
like the gcp project region staging
location and the start script has to be
scrolled along with the required
templates along with the corresponding
arguments here is the link for the
execution of the templates from jupyter
notebooks recently Google made Spa even
more powerful by enabling serverless
interactive development through dataproc
sessions in jupyter notebooks this
enables a data scientist to automate the
dataproc template execution with vertex
AI pipelines and serverless power
kubernetes complex as well here are the
recovered screenshots for execution of
the notebooks with this we are coming to
your name for the demo of the dataproc
templates we are happy to see your
feedback queries and suggestions based
on on your requirements and usage of
this templates please please feel free
to reach us at data Pro iPhone templates
iPhone support hyphen external at Google
groups.com thanks for watching and have
a great day